by first light the last rescue ships
reach the scene they find total silence
cause Renauld we got to the side of the
sinkings costly I could see it was
covered with clothes coats shoes but it
never knows what else floating around
one horse went over was honest the
lifeboats are still crowded
hunt and I'm diese border bond only one
of those boats there were dead bodies
bodies of women what the bodies of
children 12 Jesus poured water in film
I'm bitter my future father went on
board and in the stern he found a woolen
bundle a woolen blanket boys tiff with
ice Brenda Feist wonder when he took a
closer look he turned out to be me
hundred is Leo me
the child is about a year old it has
been in the boat for seven hours
oxide there's some baby oh I said that's
a baby he shifted the blanket a bit and
I could see the blue romper suit and
that used to be a sign it was a boy
Kazuma there's no way of knowing who the
baby is
but petty officer Varner thick isn't
about to abandon him
sorry partner once and he said listen
can't I have him and I said vana that
would be a good thing you haven't got
any children you're old enough I know
your wife falconer that's a good idea of
new GV a family gets a new child a boy
gets a new home and a new name Peter
after the war many children will be
searching for their parents
and many parents searched desperately
for their lost children
cabinetry of course I noticed that
couples were continually coming to see
my parents to see if I was their son by
minor done for stylish warden and of
course all these visits were estranged
from our parents were naturally
fermented and elastin many families are
reunited not Peter visors but maybe that
doesn't matter he had much to be
thankful for that were and early before
it was a family home that was full of
love and the man who found me took me in
brought me up want yo he's my father my
real father dear father under H to your
father